FEMA is calling its first test of the
new presidential alert system a success
the mass cell phone blasts went out at
2:18 Eastern Time yesterday afternoon
did you get yours the presidential alert
is meant for extreme circumstances like
terror attacks or tsunamis but the test
they say was not perfect while many
people received the alert others say
they did not Anna Werner got the first
inside look at the new system and a good
morning to you good morning senior FEMA
and FCC officials estimated more than
225 million people would receive
Wednesday's tests and yesterday after
years of preparation the alert went out
nationwide was their reaction
plenty I'm excited I feel like it's New
Years if your phone was on and you had
cell service Wednesday afternoon yeah I
guess you learned I mean I must be on a
special list that you're not on this
heard a whole cacophony of alerts going
off of the newsroom everyone's buzzing
there's a good chance you received this
presidential alert many stopped to look
at their phones there is an emergency I
think it's important that we be aware of
what we need to do while others didn't
even know what it was earlier this week
FEMA predicted about 75% of u.s. cell
phones would receive the message it said
in part presidential alert this is a
test after Wednesday's test FEMA told
CBS News if you didn't get it your
location phone make or model could have
been a factor the agency also said
active phone calls could delay the
alerts arrival so is this the same
system for the presidential alerts it
would be a similar system earlier this
week FEMA engineer Mark Lucero showed us
the type of program used to launch a
wireless emergency alert in a real
emergency the White House will work with
FEMA and a FEMA employee will put out
the blast from an undisclosed secure
location many Americans are used to
receiving phone alerts government
agencies have issued more than 40,000 of
them related to weather and missing
children since 2012 but this alert got
plenty of attention on social media
trended on Twitter and became late-night
fodder Donald Trump is the President of
the United States
he probably texted you about it today if
there's a tsunami Trump is the last
person I want to get a text from I
already get terrifying presidential
alerts on my phone
they're called the news well FEMA told
CBS News the agency is committed to
continuously improving the system right
now the presidential Alert is limited to
90 characters in the spring it will be
expanded to 360 Nora all right I heard
the buzz I heard the buzz in the office
that I'll mine and I'm Anna thank you so
much